so John when our nation was founded
there was media's essentially the
newspapers
how has the evolution of media affected
the evolution of political discourse at
the beginning of our country the editors
of the rival newspapers there was no
middle-of-the-road newspaper you were
either for one side of the other and you
either a federalist or you were with the
Jeffersonian Democrats Democratic
Republicans as they called themselves
and the editors were at each other's
throats so violently they would
sometimes get in fights in the street
and knock each other down so it was and
and you had lawmakers who were supposed
to be men of virtue as all men in those
days would be leaking documents
Alexander Hamilton the Treasury
secretary and Thomas Jefferson the
Secretary of State would leak documents
to their favorite papers in order to
attack the other and eventually George
Washington had to come in and say knock
it off fellas because this isn't good
for the country so the bitterness
carried out in the press was with us
from the founding what changed over time
is that it became in the interest of the
newspapers particularly to appeal to a
larger audience that means you didn't
want just the left or the right
you wanted both and so that created a
tradition along with a few other things
where there was an attempt to give just
the facts a kind of middle-of-the-road
perspective we are changing from that
now where there the economics of
covering the news and the the the
digital change where you now can have
anybody speaking and gaining access to
the public has created a situation where
you have a more partisan press now and
we're in the middle of trying to figure
out where that's going next so this is
interesting because a lot of people when
they talk about oh well now it's got
getting polarized and partisan you know
the good old days when you got the truth
of wisdom from you know Walter Cronkite
or whatever but but what you're talking
about is maybe what's going on now is a
little bit of a reversion back to where
we started that's right in terms of the
partisanship of the press it is a
reversion towards the early days of
America and in terms of the partisanship
of the individual members of Congress or
of the White House what is a little bit
different is that the the call to virtue
which would snap people out of their
partisanship was
is still up for grabs whether the
original the founders when they fought
like cats and dogs during the early
years of the administration's I mean
Thomas Jefferson was best friends with
John Adams and essentially then hired a
newspaper writer to undermine Adams when
he was president I mean this was a very
dirty pool the argument they were making
though was our country is new and what
is at stake is the very survival of the
American experiment and so they were
fighting for real stakes
they weren't just trying to primarily
keep power they were really trying to
make this flower bloom that they had
just planted so now the question is what
role does virtue play in the American
experience to pull people away from
their partisanship to make them work
together for common interests and what
is that shared area of common interests
what pulls them away from what the
founders knew people would behave like
dogs sometimes but they thought they
could pull away if they thought about
the common interest well is that poll
still there so there's a lot of talk
these days about a polarization of the
media or the polarization of politics in
general how much of it do you think is
due to things like social media or do
you think it was inevitable well we've
always had polarization in American
politics but there was a dose of
something else which was a call to a
higher American ideal and also voters
would vote on people based on their
virtue on there larger than
larger-than-life statesmanship which was
not partisan so you had to keep a
balance if you were being highly
partisan you kind of did it in quiet
what's changed now with social media and
also with the flood of money in in
politics is that it has encouraged
people to be more and more partisan the
louder and hotter I talk on a specific
issue the more money I'm gonna be able
to raise the more interest groups are
gonna like me and the more clicks I'm
gonna get because I'm the one making the
most flamboyant noise the problem is
that means the arguments are always
containing flamboyant noise and the
people who want to come steady measured
conversation well they're they're not
getting read on social media they're not
in charge of the interest groups that
pay millions and millions of dollars so
the system encourages people to stay a
part and that's one of the biggest
challenges Secretary of Defense
James Madison may be the greatest threat
to American democracy that polarization
and do you see a way of this getting
resolved or just get worse as get better
there have been periods of American
history where we have been the split
obviously the Civil War was a period of
great rending in the American fabric
what changed it was an actual conflict
and so we see that God forbid would be
one way to do it another would be if
there was a threat to America from
outside its borders and people would
feel an acute sense of of national pride
and patriotism but other than that this
there there doesn't appear to be at the
moment a quick fix for what is a
complicated problem for why the two
parties have gotten into a kind of
inescapable fight that they can't seem
to get themselves out of it's like we
need a shock to remind ourselves how
much commonality there is so all of that
the polarizing quibbling kind of goes
away or at least gets covered up a
little bit big changes in American
history usually happen from a shock and
it's what breaks people out of their
behavior and also which tells a lot of
the people in the rest of the country
who don't participate in presidential
elections and don't participate in
congressional elections it reminds them
that something real is at stake and
there is a vast group of Americans who
really want solutions in the middle who
don't care about the bickering and the
ideology but a lot of them don't
participate in politics and so the kind
of shock that would make people behave
who are partisans is also the kind of
shock that might draw in people who were
just apathetic and not participating in
the political system